oh
thanks I don't know why I said that yeah
um what were you gonna say
I found your board
are you serious yeah but like an
off-brand of Santa's kind of riding on
it what yeah I think he went this way
you know I saw creepy Santa on the
penthouse balcony this morning that must
be his room yeah but why the [ __ ] does
he have your board I have no idea what
are you gonna say to him I don't know I
mean I've honestly never but if he puts
up a fight you think he might put up a
fight I don't know he might that's the
situation I'd be completely unprepared
for
foreign
I don't think this card gets us up to
the penthouse
okay
we'll party
yeah let's go
a lot of information
read it yeah okay wait I need the code
two eight six oh hey
and they're definitely cool with us
coming uh me yeah that's right so worst
case scenario you're cool to go in yeah
do not go there do not go there okay
that'd be fun
hey guys
I swear we're
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my God
[Applause]
by the way you can't be in Benin hi oh
this is my friend Sam hey nice to meet
you sir I'm glad you're here thanks for
having us yeah you want something to
drink yeah
[Applause]
okay thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey man I think you have my board what
my skateboard I think you may have
picked it up what's skateboard I left it
by the pool it's got like a brightly
colored Jack come out kid hey you want
to dance yeah yeah come on
[Music]
thank you
hey
okay
oh my God your head is like a black hole
for pain
[Music]
yeah yeah come on let's go find your
skateboard come on
[Music]
I've never been hit in the face before
o'clock
in the morning
life doesn't seem to be the same
it's beautiful